if you don't have military spending
works you add an iPhone 6 to an F-16
that's going to be like 20 million
dollars on the contract
[Music]
this is StarTalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist and today we've got a
cosmic queries Edition
featuring
uaps got with me my co-host Paul
Mercurio Paul welcome back to the show
hey thanks for having me great to see
you again Neil welcome back from your
travels around the world so we've we've
got someone who is uniquely positioned
to comment on the uaps just remind
everyone what UAP stand for unidentified
aerial phenomenon we've got a long time
friend long time colleague uh recently
tasked by the U.S government NASA in
particular to investigate uh uaps in all
ways that they might lend themselves to
become accessible to scientific inquiry
David spurgle David spurgle theoretical
astrophysicist we have many overlapping
years at Princeton University where he
is an Emeritus professor and now he's
president of the Simons Foundation but
more specifically more importantly for
this podcast he's the chair of the NASA
independent study team on unidentified
aerial phenomena so David welcome to
start talk
great to be here so how did you step in
this sorry how did you land in this
I don't want to lead the witness okay
how did you come to be chosen as the
chair of this committee by NASA
so I've done a lot with NASA over the
years I've been involved with a number
of NASA missions uh
and I feel NASA uh has done a lot of
great science and really enabled my
career
so what I got a call from the head of
science at Nasa then had assigned to
NASA Thompson
asking me to share this committee
my first response was what committee why
am I doing this and then he said you
know he really wanted someone
who had a broad scientific Vision who
wasn't didn't really have an agenda here
um and also as um someone who now leads
the Science Foundation I'm not someone
who gets funded by Ness
so they wanted someone who really had an
independent perspective independent both
of us itself and
um no real kind of agenda here right I
mean this is an area with a lot of
strong feelings and I can vouch for your
uh Independence your rationality your
sensibility your politic uh in the sense
that when people are disagreeing you
will find ways to bring people together
uh and that is rare among people in
general
and uh in the Sciences I we might have a
few more in the Sciences than in than
you find on social media
but whatever that pyramid is I've you
for me you're at the top of that pyramid
so I concur with all of the efforts that
people put in to get you to lead this
but let me ask what is the difference
between your committee and other
committees that have testified in front
of Congress or other efforts that
Congress has engaged to try to get to
the bottom of the uaps
so our mission in some ways is narrower
right our mission is tell NASA what they
can do that can contribute to
understanding
right so our job is not to say resolve
every UAP event right NASA has passed
um when you say resolve you mean here's
a here's a light in the sky we don't
understand it figure it out that's not
your task that's not our job or we have
like this we have this massive alien
being in a warehouse in Arizona please
go in like Jeff Goldblum and make it go
away that kind of thing right right well
our job is to say okay what is NASA's
role if there is something like that
right so you know I think of this in
terms of okay let's say there was some
thing we didn't understand right there's
some rock you don't understand well you
know NASA's done this before we bought
black rocks from the Moon what do you do
you make it available to everyone right
like you make it you want to have things
open to the whole scientific Community I
think our job was to say how do we
address questions like this as
scientists
and just to back you up there so
scientists are trained to ask questions
trained to to train to not agree with
each other actually
and being a friend of Neil's man that's
a big thing with him is just not agree
well pray not not to believe right so I
think what could turn out to be one of
the big science results of the year is
this claim from South Korea that they
made a high temperature superconductor
right if that works that moves power at
room temperature all sorts of great
stuff
everyone's reaction is I don't believe
it I want to make the same thing in my
lab
and see if I can do it and what's
happening right now is there are
literally tens maybe hundreds of labs
throughout the world trying to reproduce
the results from South Korea and all
their status public it's all on the
archive and you go in and you you test
it and you see if you can verify it and
that's as you know how we do things as
scientists right yeah it's healthy
skepticism especially if a claim is
extraordinary that's put on the table
yeah absolutely
I have a question as a layperson for
both of you in dealing with NASA is
there institutionalized thinking
sometimes that you have to overcome
right in other words or they come in
with a preconceived notion or agenda
that
you even though it may not be spoken is
sort of beneath the surface and you have
to sort of
navigate
um
but that's the whole point of David
being independent I mean he's not coming
from within a NASA establishment to do
this
does he Buzzy does he meet this does
there is there some of that at times you
know and also NASA uh isn't one really
monolithic agency right there's a piece
of it that's concerned with
sending humans on the space station
right and that's very sick it's a
anything
that deals with putting humans in space
tends to be very conservative and
careful because they don't want things
to blow up right so there's like that
kind of a piece of NASA's culture is
that careful engineering mentality
and the piece that I was mostly working
with is the science mission directorate
right and culturally that's people who
come they're science phds who lead that
and that's it's that part of the agency
very much has a science culture I would
say more than the Engineering Management
culture the point is you've got multiple
cultures coming from different places
and people come in and out of NASA so
while they're career people at Nasa
there's there's fresh blood moving
through there with quite free with quite
a bit of frequency and many people who
do work quote for NASA they're separate
from NASA because they have independent
appointments at universities right so to
have the idea that everyone at Nasa is
in some kind of mono think
um that's this is this the last of all
agencies for which that could possibly
true be true is NASA well you know look
as as just a lay person as a citizen you
don't know know how this works and life
is political and and the world is
political and you don't know like well
okay well are you getting a call
sometimes from the administration saying
look we uh there's a UAP it's not going
to be good to talk about this right now
wait six months you you know I'm
imagining it doesn't work that way but
you know for the person looking on the
outside looking in it uh unlike the two
of you it's it's it's refreshing and
good to know that there are checks and
balances in having healthy independent
Skeptics out there working with the
agency as opposed to you know being cow
Towing to them or sort of carrying their
pills of water so to speak
so you uh who's on your committee what
types of people are on your committee
we've got a great group of people
um from uh a number of scientists from a
number of fields oceanography
atmospheric physics
um some people who study exoplanets
planetary scientists
uh we have a lot of people from the
remote sensing Community including
people who've worked with the defense
department in remote sensing uh we have
two members of the FAA and on the
committee a number of criminal Aviation
Administration yeah right um Naja Drake
who's a science writer so uh we have a
lot of different perspectives and it's
been a really engaged committee that
I've learned a lot from my fellow
committee members excellent excellent
let's go to our q a here uh so Paul did
you collect you I've no I haven't seen
them I don't think David has seen them
but you have and these are all patreon
supporters who get the exclusive axis
they are that's a new rule that we put
into play so uh go right ahead uh try to
start a softball and David just a
suggestion it sure will not mine I think
the committee needs a social media
influencer that's all I'm saying I mean
they're big out there and you may want
to put one on because they have a lot of
power now anyway uh here we go uh Troy
from Virginia regarding the UAE P that
was a cube in a bubble what if in
between the clear sphere in Cube there's
a vacuum that allows the ship to
maneuver through our atmosphere in the
Unseen ways mentioned in Congress
because I'm reminded that uh because
many of us saw the testimonies of uh I
guess whistleblowers what what is that
committee that a congressional committee
that uh
uh that that posted that hearing oh the
complete waste of time committee
no some
you know one of the things and I think
this is going to affect how we answer a
lot of these questions
we looked at the reports we saw and the
thing that struck us most was
the lack of data quality
so what do I mean by that like
if I have an image of something that
look strange like I'd like to know be
convinced I understand the instrument
that took the image
convinced that I'm not seeing artifacts
ideally you'd like to see just to be
clear I have to clarify what artifact is
so if you have a brand new instrument
um in fact it's more likely to happen in
a brand new instrument than a
well-tested instrument that if you if
you have yet to characterize
how that instrument is going to obtain
and hand you data then you don't always
know what you're looking at whether
you're looking at is real or something
the instrument put in there and until
it's properly characterized you don't
know how to subtract it out and so we
call those artifacts in this business so
let me give you a good way to make one
you can do this experiment at home
go take a picture of a friend now
everyone's told you take a picture of
someone with the sun behind the
photographer and the light on the
person's face right that gives the best
picture
don't listen to what people told you
have them stand with the sun behind them
coming in at some odd angle to the
camera
you'll find that what that will do most
often with your camera is produce a
terrible picture
often with a funny shaped light come
across coming across your camera and
that's the light of the sun bouncing
around inside your cell phone camera
and no no no David it's an aura from the
person just just it could be it could be
the aura
deals it takes another whole picture
with people involved I don't think they
have much of an aura so
but you know
an example of something that's been
understood is there's a famous image in
the UFO community of these rotating
triangles that was taken I think by an
F-16
and you can reproduce this by taking the
F-16 camera
putting the Sun at an at an angle
relative to the camera and that will
produce a triangle shaped Optical effect
and that's just the Sun's light bouncing
around inside and that would be an
artifact right not a real object right
the F-16 camera sits on a mount and it's
not designed to do astronomical studies
it's designed to like follow enemy
targets
so when it's tracking that Target and
the cable wraps around fully around it
it automatically swings it around it
rapidly
and undoes the cable wrap
keeping track on the target
and uh that produces rapid rotation in
the object and can reproduce it
now one of the things that provides a
bit of an obstacle a serious obstacle to
looking at a lot of the UFO reports or
UAP reports from the military
is that they're classified
now why are they classified not because
of what's in the image but how the image
is taken
if you take data with the camera on an
F16
that's image is automatically classified
any
um image taken with military cameras and
particularly anything taken from space
with our spy satellites are those images
are classified because if you see the
image you can study it and learn about
our military capabilities so that's been
an obstacle I think to transparency in
this area is that many of the best known
events are taken by military planes and
then the military classifies it
so that's why we have not gone through
the classified data we don't have we
want to operate entirely in the open I
have no classified clearances and we
made sure that we structured our
committee so while some people at
clearances most of us didn't so we could
do a completely open report but that
means that we're relying on the aaro
that's a committee an organization set
up within the defense department
coordinating both DOD and in the
intelligence Community uh led by ashanka
Patrick that and they have the charge of
reporting to Congress
on the individual events
um and they have full access to the
classified data so David why didn't
anybody say this earlier that any
military image basically is going to be
classified so that we don't reveal our
capacity to obtain data because everyone
is thinking it's classified because the
government knows something that we don't
know about the thing that's in the
picture so why wasn't why isn't that
made much clearer it should have been
made that should be made clear I mean
that's I think that's known by the
people involved and there's some people
who know that about classification
um there was a famous incident during
the uh Trump Administration where there
was uh people in the intelligence
Community got very upset at president
Trump because he made public an image of
an Iranian missile site
and in doing so he revealed to the
Iranians or satellite capabilities
so normally we would only talk about or
they would only talk about what's seen
they would make public the image but he
wanted to show everyone the images we
know he likes to show stuff that was
concerning because we sort of leaked
intelligence by revealing an image like
that little known fact he still has that
photo in his closet in Mar-A-Lago
it's all by the toilet
well best thinking happens
this is Malcolm Marfan there are a
number of reasons why people might be
afraid to report UAP sightings do they
say where they're from uh this uh
Malcolm from uh trinvago or trinbago I
don't know if I'm mispronounced why
didn't you say that I want to hear where
these people are from oh okay all right
okay definitely
um there are a number of reasons why
people might be able uh afraid to report
UAP sightings people are afraid of being
ridiculed or ostracized others are
afraid that they'll be labeled as
mentally ill still others are afraid
that they will be investigated by the
government this stigma has chilling
effect on the reporting of UAP sightings
it makes it difficult for researchers to
gather data on UAP and therefore that
has also made it difficult to understand
what these phenomenon are how can we
reduce the stigma around reporting UAP
sightings
so David let me just slip something in
there my my thought is it's not that
there's stigma around a UAP sighting
it's that there's stigma around anyone's
assumption
that the UAP is visiting intelligent
aliens from outer space if I say I saw
something in the sky I don't know what
it is let's investigate it who's gonna
who's gonna fault me for that but if I'm
going to say I saw aliens today that's a
whole other leap that people have made
that would get a giggle Factor so isn't
there a line in the sand here that we
can draw well it depends who you are so
you're a professional scientist a
professional astronomer you say you
something you see something in the weird
in the sky it's like yeah that's your
job to see weird things I look up all
the time right right there's stuff up
there yeah there is a lot of stigma
particularly for commercial pilots and
for military Pilots
to report anomalies
so you know
um this is something we've heard from a
lot of Pilots it's something that was
talked about in the Congressional
hearings and it's very clear that there
are if you see something odd as a pilot
um
there's a sense that oh yeah you're
you're Source you know let's not imagine
that that Oddity is
an alien spacecraft Oddities are just
not reported there's a culture that keep
that wasn't collecting that the military
has made an effort to change that
culture that's why the number of UAP
reports in the last two years is so much
higher than the past because people are
encouraged if you see something strange
reported no okay let's talk about just
two classes of events that are certainly
there that you want to make sure get
recorded we all heard about this Chinese
balloon
that flew over the United States and by
the way it was in full high resolution
you know so it wasn't some fuzzy object
you know it was like fully well
identifiable right but I one that was
very clearly uh
a Chinese balloon but initially those
balloons have probably been for at least
what I've read in the press and again
stress I you know I have no clearances
um this is what I read in the Washington
Post right the Chinese were probably
flying balloons and spying on U.S Navy
operations
for years yeah and that's right probably
some of these balloons were seen by
Commercial and Military Pilots as uaps
they saw something strange
but because of the stigma those aren't
getting reported so one of the things we
want to do is reduce that stigma just to
get those revolts
but can't you push back on the stigma by
the people that are prying a stigma to
it they're the ones that should have a
stigma that's narrow thinking it's based
on insecurity that we are it's also sort
of a little self-aggrandizing that we
could be the only things in in the
entire universe only living beings so so
why why hasn't there been able to be a
shift for years it's been like this
right oh you said you saw us on alien
you're crazy no no I think to say you've
seen an alien to know that it's an alien
is taking a big step this is what I was
making yeah to say hey I see something I
don't understand
but when even people say that they get
the stigma you sorry I don't give them I
said tell me about it what does it look
like so that's well you got video you
got images so that's so that's what I
one of the things we are aiming to do in
this report is
you see something weird report it and
give us good data right now most of the
time that weird thing is going to be an
airplane a balloon a drone it's weird to
you but given more data we'll figure it
out
sometimes it's going to be something
interesting interesting could just you
know knowing about for the US military
to know about a Chinese spy drone or
balloon that's pretty interesting they'd
like that data
and then there's phenomenon and my
favorite on this list is lightning
Sprites these lightning Sprites are
amazing they're upward going lightning
and these were reported by pilots for
years they saw these weird lightning
flashes going up they were these amazing
patterns and no one believed them
and some of them look really bizarre but
they're not normal lightning bolts right
it's like it's like a sheet of
electricity sort of I don't know how
else to describe it they're really and
it was only with the development of
high-speed cameras and dedicated uh
instruments to go after it that people
believe that they're there and started
to understand them and David this is
only in the last few years right where
we have authentic high-speed uh imagery
of them right and they really represent
something where I think the kind of the
whole UFO stigma thing affected the
discovery of lightning spreads those
people
I saw this really weird flashing lights
oh you're seeing aliens Sons you know
they're really interesting
um but you know they're different
phenomenon right so
set aside those other you know the most
you know exciting interpretations just
removing the stigma collecting data in a
systematic way you see something that's
surprising to you
collect data I mean I think that like
that's a message we want for kind of for
everybody and data for most people is
very good imagery if you're a scientist
you bring out some other tools and
instruments right of course and um I may
be jumping it up ahead but like one of
the things I think want to be
encouraging NASA to do is actually
develop apps for people's cell phones
so you see something have a standard app
that takes an image records the metadata
metadata's location a little time that
sort of thing time how the image was
taken what the focus of your camera is
um you could incorporate with that data
because your phone records amazing
things your phone measures magnetic
field it measures the local
gravitational field that's how it knows
its orientation your phone's of course
recording sound
um and you could imagine
combining all that data
encrypting it so people can't
um easily at least
edit the images and Photoshop in
something interesting you would know
that from the
the metadata
and
then if you've got the time and location
and you see something interesting and
someone else
10 miles away see something interesting
from a different perspective that's the
same event and you've got four or five
observations
we could combine them get distance
velocity acceleration
usually it's going to turn out to be
something conventional but then you
understand and you're not you're not
beholden to the limitations and vagaries
of the five senses our biological senses
which are highly susceptible to error so
listen and you're both brilliant but I
have to just jump in here I look at look
at how many apps I have I can't handle
another app okay David
um
you've got a lot of apps you're not
losing using I'm using my Starbucks my
years agree with David delete half your
apps your iPhone is already removing
half your apps that you haven't touched
in months so that's the one with a
little Cloud next to it right yes
exactly so what do we do his job for him
you are the data taking device that's
out there here we go ready another one
yes Thomas Cochran from Kansas City if
these uaps AC Mo or Kansas City Kansas
it's says Kansas City okay yeah uh if
these uaps are as common as the latest
hearings imply why aren't more common
folk seeing them and posting what they
see everyone has a camera in their
pocket nowadays why hasn't there been a
more scientific method to studying these
uaps yeah David what do you think of
that yes
I agree
uh yeah no you'd like to see e
a high quality images with multiple
angles uh once you've got those events
you know the FAA has radar data that it
has recorded for and you keep so let's
say you see something strange we could
go to radar
you could not turn it around and say
what would you like this is how we
thought about this you know you have
these events where you've got a fuzzy
picture that's ambiguous
and we're asked to like what do you
conclude from this and what you conclude
from this is
I can't tell I need better data
right and I think of this as and there's
been a lot of scientists astronomical
phenomenon like this where you see
something people see something they
don't understand it's strange
and the first thing you do is collect
better data in a systematic way
and most of the time it turns out to be
something conventional that you
understand
and every now and then it turns out to
be something surprising and interesting
but if it's surprising and interesting
you're going to want
multi-wavelength data you're going to
want to have Optical data from many
angles cameras many angles rate you know
radar data and so on and pieced together
a full picture
and just to be clear in our field Paul
we uh we're not satisfied with just one
wavelength band when we're studying an
object in the sky if I find something
really interesting with my telescope and
it's really really interesting people
will pull all stops and pull out all the
big guns all the varieties of telescopes
we have because rarely is an object only
talking to you in one band of light
so one of my favorite examples is of
unidentified things in the sky that took
a long time to figure out are what we
call gamma ray bursts these were bursts
of gamma radiation
seen first by spy satellites that were
designed to look for nuclear tests
and because they were seen by them they
were actually classified for two three
years
until they convinced themselves that
they weren't coming from Earth from
space so then they let the astronomers
know about them
and it took astronomers a long time to
figure out they first thought they were
in the galaxy
and uh in fact Neil and my late
colleague Bowden pachinsky someone who I
think we uh both worked with and admired
and got dried tragically young of cancer
um came up with this idea with others
that they this could be something like
an extra Galactic event people figured
out eventually that these might be the
merger of two neutron stars
and proposed that
in fact all of the gold in the universe
comes from these mergers
and only in the last couple years did we
see one of these mergers happen where we
saw gravitational waves from it we saw
x-rays from it gamma rays Optical
radiation radio signal
putting all those pieces together we got
the story of this merger of this
incredibly powerful explosion in some
ways the most powerful in the universe
uh these explosions and and it turns out
by understanding then that's how we
understand where gold and platinum and
all the heavy elements come from so you
start with something you don't
understand that's a bright flash
and it literally leads you to gold
and that that's how we work
Paul you got another question I do
Joseph Focus uh uh I do not have where
he's from I feel pretty confident
assuming we aren't being visited by
beings from another planet as far as I
know Earth has nothing special to offer
that can't be found in abundance
elsewhere elsewhere well how about the
Kardashians buddy Anyway
come on just having a bad and stuffed
crust pizza come on yeah really uh but
given the deglassified albeit fuzzy
footage in the admittance uh of them not
really knowing what it was they were
looking at what are the current leading
hypotheses in the scientific not
military community
also have you guys inform the military
that HD cameras now exist so
it is you look at fuzzy pictures and say
wait
why how come we have incredible cell
phone pictures of everything else
why don't we have high quality pictures
and that's one of the things that I
think has encouraged us to encourage
NASA to develop uh better ways of people
using it's because you have your 60 year
old Uncle who can't take a picture at a
wedding properly taking the picture like
is my what button do I push maybe that's
part of the problem
um
as a 62 year old um
I'm sorry he was 70. I said 70. you did
say 70. I thought I heard you say 70.
yeah yeah
um
yeah I mean some of this is with the
military data I think a very interesting
difference I would say in culture
between a military pilot a commercial
pilot and a scientist
you're a commercial pilot flying from
you know Denver to Chicago and you see
something really odd and interesting on
your right hand side
once you realize it is not a threat to
your plane your job is to keep going you
don't say hey I see something really
cool and interesting I don't know what
it is I'm going to turn the plane around
and have a look I'm going to try to
figure this out no I see if our pilot I
say everybody on the right side of the
plane take a picture of this that's what
I would say okay but like
you know your job as a part is to get
everyone safely to Chicago right and
you're a military pilot your job is to
carry out your mission
as a scientist my job is I see something
weird
my job like that's the exciting thing my
job is to figure out I got to
investigate it and we go get more data
we come back to it we live for weird
stuff that's right but
you know when a lot of these things are
being seen by say commercial military
Pilots
the cameras they have are not designed
for this right we talked about you know
your camera on a military plane is
designed to pick have very wide field of
view
it's designed to pick up enemy threats
it's not designed to have very clean
images that are reproducible free of
artifacts and defects that we talked
about
um so you're kind of prone to these
sorts of problems so these military
judges of science mode right you flick a
button and then it goes into curiosity
mode well I was just saying why not in
all seriousness why not equip these
planes with with better cameras together
this data have the cameras they
currently have or put a second camera on
I mean I would think the technology they
give them an iPhone 6 that would be
better
well it's really it's really small it's
only got two gigs it's only got two gigs
but iPhone 6 could take better images
than anything they've been showing us
this is something where I think
um it's I see this actually as an
opportunity for citizen science I think
this is something where we shouldn't be
asking
the military you know hey if you don't
have military spending works you add an
iPhone 6 to an F-16 that's going to be
like 20 million dollars
right you know
um and then the cover for the iPhone 6
that's another 20 million dollars right
there right
um but uh
I think the opportunity is actually this
is a special cable to dream right right
you're gonna have to dongle this toggle
right here this is 40 million dollars
right here for each Place yeah that's
crazy no but I I think this is a good
system science opportunity I think I
love the idea of an app that is
streamlined user-friendly even 70 year
old uncles can use and uh I'd be great
to see that become something real
because we would all have it and it
would be one of the more frequently used
apps or just even have it right in the
in the in the wings of your uh maybe not
on the first screen but I'm definitely
on the second screen of your uh over
stuff and I think it just sends out a
message that you see something strange
get the data yeah and then we'll fit you
know and then we work together to figure
it out because that's what we do so just
in terms of strange things something
that people should keep in mind because
a lot of the reports that you get when
you look at them are of flashing lights
okay why do we put flashing lights on
things so they're seen you put flashing
lights on Bridges you put flashing
lights on planes you put flashing lights
on drugs and lighthouses yeah
lighthouses if you don't want to be seen
you don't put a flashing light on
when the ukrainians attacked Moscow with
the Drone it doesn't come with flashing
lights
when the Russians attacked Odessa no
flashing lights and when we fly our
military planes in
effectively kind of War mode when
they're you know they may put blights on
if they're doing something in commercial
airspace
you don't do that so
let's imagine and I you know that that
we are being someone comes to visit
Earth from outside
uh there's two possibilities they want
to be seen
or they don't want to be sick
they want to be seen
you know they're gonna land
in front of the White House
they don't want to be seen
they're not putting flashing lights on
so you know flashing lights are almost
always airplanes or drugs
are flashing lights events but flesh you
know a lot of the most uh common
conventional and kind of easily
explained events well we time for just a
couple more questions all right here we
go two more maybe two more okay all
right greetings from Sheboygan Falls
Middle School in Wisconsin nice
there you go my question is
it's uh Matt Berg uh Sheboygan Falls
Middle School in Wisconsin my question
is what it means to be uh is what it
means to be anomalous in the first place
my students and I discuss the importance
of basing uh final conclusions of any
experiment on accumulated data when
locking uh when sorry when looking at a
data set at what point does a piece of
data move from what is considered to be
an anomaly to something that is just
considered part of the data set overall
and an expected result
I think in a sense once you can explain
it it's not anomalous right those that
Chinese balloon is not a UAP anymore it
was when it was first seen we didn't
know what it was it's IAP it's
identified aerial identified phenomena
which ironically was made in the U.S I'm
just throwing putting that out there no
ironically it was copied off of the
those balloons that Google was was
designed in the U.S made in China like
many things
um yeah I think of this problem of
looking for anomalies like looking for a
needle in the haystack
and there's two ways I know of finding
needles and Haystacks either you have a
really good idea of what a needle looks
like
and this gets to how artificial
intelligence or machine would do this
you then design a match filter that
looks for a needle
and you just look I'm only looking for
needles and it would do better job than
your eye brain combination would because
it's the the filter is is precise okay
as you say I know what hay looks like
and I have a very good model of how hay
looks like
and I am looking for everything
from hay
and this gets to what an anomaly is if
you're going through a haystack
um you know that's uh and you're looking
for things that don't look like hey
that's looking for anomalies now a lot
of the fine things you find in Haystacks
get back to that dog walk and stuff
okay so you know it's
yeah not useful yeah right so it's not
it may not be a needle but it may be
something else but wait wait but it's
only anomalous if you didn't know it was
going to be there so if you so you have
a hay model and you have a poop model so
that now you can separate both of those
from what still might be the needle but
you have to know in advance you might be
finding poop David's saying it's
anomalous because it's also because it's
not useful to anything no it's anomalous
because no no because it's a hey model
it's not hey and you say hey oh I've
discovered something
barrels of hay in a barn have poop in
them okay good I understand that I now
have a hay model and a poop mark and I'm
now interested in things that aren't hay
or poop
found a horseshoe right you know you
sort of you identify what's there and
you find anomalies and you understand
them and that's how we proceed and then
they're not anomalies right and then
they're anomalies so you know you go
through this list of here's weird things
and then they're anomalies and I think
if we look at the events that have been
reported they're a bunch that you look
at and you say hey those are anomalies
we don't understand them
and you want to understand them better
get better data and then we're going to
need is you know we want to have data on
lots of wavelengths we want to have lots
of observations
um you know and you I look at the
reports that we've heard about and you
say those those are interesting enough
that they Merit investigation maybe we
should be looking anomalies more closely
but not interesting and not not complete
enough that we know it's there
the part one last question if we can go
through it fast go absolutely Sean Raven
fine uh uh don't have location on the
subject of UAP UFOs it seems kind of
unlikely to me that extraterrestrials we
Traverse space in something we would
recognize as a ship imagine that any
civilization that regularly crosses
Interstellar distances would probably
use some kind of Wormhole technology or
something we never even thought of yet
but this raises the question if uaps
aren't alien ships but it turns out that
they're also not something mundane like
weather balloons and such that do we
have a third option guesses as to what
they may be
so uh let me agree in the sense that if
I if I think about what tech
um life on other planets
um we know that the Stars around us are
typically 100 million years or a billion
years older than us are younger than us
so any civilization you share any life
form is 100 million years a billion
years behind us in evolution in a sense
or ahead of us
and behind us they're bacteria they're
not traveling ahead of us
I think of the the time scale for us for
technical logical evolution is such that
if you take someone from 1923 and bring
them forward
they'll kind of understand the world
today cars are better playing someone
take someone from
10 23
to today it's magic thousand years is
huge steps in technological evolution
100 million years a hundred thousand
steps like that
any sis uh alien civilization capable of
space travel is going to be so Advanced
compared to us that their technology
will not be recognizable and will look
like magic it will look like magic so if
you're looking at some technology that
turns out to be
like hey they're better than I thought
drones are well that probably is because
the military or some one is doing Tech
development and is pushing the edge of
drones so you know my guess is
um a bunch of the anomalies
um are drones and their drones that the
military is developing and that's a
class of events and another class of
events and this is a national security
concern is if the there are Chinese or
Russian or other uh North Korean
um are developing some uh drone
technology that are being developed to
spy on our planes or our naval ships
um that's a that's something of National
Security concern and we want to
understand that technology and I know
that we're developing
pretty cool Technologies just to spy on
other countries and monitor their
military and that's sort of the job of
the intelligence community in the
military here David give us one
summative thought before we switch
subjects here I think the best summary I
saw of what we were doing
um came from someone on Twitter and I'll
take out the expletives
um
you know those scientists they don't
believe they just want better data and
you know I think that's what we're
coming at this we don't you comment
something where you see something
uh you don't understand rather than
jumping to believing the most exciting
hypothesis
you say all right how do I collect
better data to understand what's going
on this is something I don't understand
and of course in any scientific
conference when two scientists are in
heated argument at the end of the day
you're going to go have a beer because
you're going to say to each other we
need better data to resolve things or
you're going to say now that wasn't dog
poop in the hay that is a I've never
learned so much about dog poop in one
conversation thank you to both of you by
the way yes of course well you know look
you got to get training somewhere
exactly I got to put it out there when I
was a kid in the Glory Days of dog
walking where you didn't have to clean
up after them because that's how old I
am I use that Revenue to buy my first
telescope
wow you have six inch reflector and my
first camera and dark room equipment so
it I lived in a big old apartment
complex 50 cents per dog per walk and
but because no one cleaned up dog poop I
have acute awareness of where my foot
lands in the street ever since then even
though it's not necessary anymore
[Laughter]
who created a radar that has to be
technologically developed more well
David thanks for that bit of sort of
sage level-headed assessment of what's
going on out there we're all excited to
see what comes of this I can't wait for
my app and we all have to agree that
Paul has way too many apps on his iPhone
uh so he won't not be a participant in
these discoveries
while the alien is trying to shake his
hand I don't miss the data
and my 75 year old Uncle not 60 year old
Uncle will have a problem with his
finger in front of the camera lens so
that's my only skepticism of this
conversation is relying on us to give
you quality data but whatever it is it's
some data rather than no data actually
relying more on the wisdom of crowds you
may take crappy data but if we've got 10
people taking data the combined data is
actually almost always quite good yeah
that's true but indeed so David thanks
for being on Star Talk my pleasure all
right guys so this has been Star Talk
Cosmic queries Edition focusing on uaps
which we all know is just a rebranding
of UFOs by the US government until next
time Neil deGrasse Tyson here bidding
you to keep looking up
[Music]
thank you